I tried to stay off of pornography,
man.
That's one of my biggest arch nemesis.
Pornography.
Why I eat to live with these rich people for a while speaking to pornography.
The day used to masturbate at night and I would sneak out there in the kitchen.
This is back when the family,
he had like a family computer,
you know,
and he was in one part of the house,
right.
And he's over there just in the glow of that screen row.
And that's back when the monitors were big,
you know?
And he's just over there just fucking looking for the devil.
And he ended up getting divorced and it was,
I think a lot of it was because of that.
The worst is if you're jerking off with a hat on Bro,
you're going to hell.
That's almost French thing you can do jacking off Williams Straw.
Kentucky Derby has.
Yeah,
but it's a worse hat to jack off or attacking Jamia topic cause you have to
balance yourself.
I'm fucking chimney sweep paths
the best to be one of those Chinese Hasbro.
Cause if you squat down low enough to the ground,
you can almost hide under it.
And
the other things that'd be dope,
Bruh.
The most confusing it would be like one of them Daniel Boone.
Raccoon
tail of your eye.
You pushed it.
You blow into the tails.
No,
it
scared the fuck out of my way with his tail.
Right.
I'm about to finish.
He had distracted by the tail God damn.
Choking up dusty coon for
and it's harder,
Jackie limb,
you're breathing out real fast.
Yeah,
it's more of an intake sport.